-Finally, guys, what is
Thanksgiving without football?
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're alright.
Earlier tonight,
the Seattle Seahawks
faced off against
the San Francisco 49ers.
Now, as you know,
at the end of every season,
they give out awards
like Most Valuable Player.
But they also give out awards
during the season, too.
I'll show you what I mean.
It's time for
"Tonight Show Superlatives."
-♪ "Tonight Show Superlatives" ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Our first player
is from the 49ers.
It's George Kittle.
He was voted...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Kind of old.
Next up, from the Seahawks,
is DeeJay Dallas.
[ Laughter ]
He was voted...
[ Laughter, applause ]
Next up, from the 49ers,
is Corey Luciano.
He was voted...
[ Laughter ]
Next up, from the Seahawks,
is Michael Jackson.
He was voted...
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Beat it.
-Next up, from the Seahawks,
is Levi Bell.
He was voted...
[ Laughter ]
Next up, from the Seahawks,
is Colby Parkinson.
He was voted...
[ Applause ]
Welcome.
Next, from the Seahawks,
is Jon Rhattigan.
He was voted...
[ Laughter, applause ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Next, from the 49ers,
is Jon Feliciano.
He was voted...
[ Laughter,
cheers and applause ]
Next up, from the 49ers,
is Jake Tonges.
He was voted...
[ Laughter ]
I'm mad.
[ Applause ]
Finally, from the Seahawks,
is Will Dissly.
He was voted...
There you have it.
Those are your superlatives.